Which scene in The Batman is giving audiences
"chills?"
Even Robert Pattinson was caught off guard
by this scene – plus, a behind-the-scenes
look at how the detective elements came about.
All that and more, right here!
By and away, people seem to love "The Batman."
With Robert Pattinson in the mask, the Caped
Crusader's latest solo adventure sees him
responding to a series of murders perpetrated
by a villain calling himself Riddler.
To solve the crimes and prevent anyone else
from dying, Batman will have to descend into
the seedy underbelly of Gotham to uncover
the truth, unraveling a conspiracy in the
process that threatens everything he once
believed about the city.
From Batman beating up a group of thugs harassing
an innocent man to the thrilling car chase
involving Batman and Penguin, there's plenty
to sink your teeth into.
And naturally, fans have taken to social media
to voice their love and admiration toward
the film, hyping it up.
One scene in particular appears to have stoked
fans' excitement.
And the good news is that it comes early in
the film's run.
It's become commonplace in Batman movies for
the opening scene to revolve around the villain.
For "The Dark Knight," that involved a thrilling
heist involving Joker and a few other nobodies
wanting to steal the mob's money.
In "The Dark Knight Rises," director Christopher
Nolan upped the ante yet again by introducing
viewers to Bane in high-flying fashion as
he hijacks a plane.
"The Batman" carries on this tradition by
opening the film with Riddler spying on the
home of Gotham City mayor Don Mitchell Jr.
It then cuts to Riddler inside of his house,
ready to strike and instill fears into the
hearts of Gothamites.
It's incredibly effective at establishing
the film's tone and displaying how much of
a threat Riddler is.
This isn't just a guy telling riddles as he's
been portrayed in other Batman media.
He's a terrifying serial killer, to the point
where the scene feels like something out of
"Zodiac" than a superhero movie.
It's proven to be so effective that numerous
people have taken to social media to say how
much they loved the sequence.
One Twitter user wrote:
"The opening scene is so powerful and one
of my favorite scenes in all of film."
Those sentiments were echoed by another user,
who had this to say,
"Can't stop thinking about #TheBatman and
THAT opening scene.
Definitely not gonna be able to sleep much
tonight."
It seems as if the impact of the scene isn't
lost upon later views, either.
As a third user wrote:
"That opening man.
2nd time seeing it and it still sends chills."
It isn't just casual fans who are being taken
aback by "The Batman" opening scene either.
Prior to the film's release, Robert Pattinson
spoke with Variety about the movie, and even
he admits that when he watched the sequence
for the first time, it was unlike anything
he had seen before.
The actor mentioned,
"I watched a rough cut of the movie by myself.
And the first shot is so jarring from any
other Batman movie that it's just kind of
a totally different pace."
Pattinson went on to say that the tone of
that scene was pretty much what director Matt
Reeves had envisioned doing from the very
beginning:
"It was what Matt was saying from the first
meeting I had with him: 'I want to do a '70s
noir detective story, like 'The Conversation.’
And I kind of assumed that meant the mood
board or something, the look of it.
But from the first shot, it's, 'Oh, this actually
is a detective story.'"
It may take some viewers by surprise to see
Batman in full noir mode, but he's the world's
greatest detective for a reason.
And that reason is something Pattinson only
learned after he nabbed the part:
"There's a lot of stuff where he's in amongst
the cops.
Normally, when you see Batman he arrives and
beats people up.
But he's having conversations, and there are
emotional scenes between them, which I don't
think have been in any of the other movies."
Indeed, from the opening scene to the end
credits, "The Batman" is unlike any Caped
Crusader movie that's come before, and it
sets a new bar for the future of the franchise.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.